[Music]
[Music]
i wonder who is this
what's up everybody carlos here mcu fans
have been talking since before one
division even premiered
about what surprise marvel character
would play a big role in this story
and what actor would show up and turn
the internet upside down
did we get that in this episode major
spoilers up ahead
this is easy canada's nerd alert
nine days ago maximoff stormed our
facility
stole the vision's body and resurrected
him
but that's in direct violation of
section 36b of the sokovia accords
and the vision's own living will he
didn't want to be anybody's weapon
following episode 4 which mainly focused
on sword and the real world
outside the anomaly or the hex as darcy
now calls it
starting to catch on
this episode brings us back into west
view hitting that nostalgia button real
hard with a pitch perfect rendition of
an 80s sitcom
the opening credits here are of course
on point even giving us a glimpse of
vision as a baby which is adorable
and unsettling because we all know that
when vision was a baby
he actually looked like this
we continue to see the cracks in wanda
and visions tv reality
with vision being more suspicious than
ever of the situation they currently
find themselves in
and wanda doing more and more to keep
the spell going
it's a nice progression from the
curiosities of the previous episodes
but now there's an interesting new
wrinkle the twins
this episode leans heavily on the theme
of family wanda and vision are now
parents of two bouncing baby boys
sorry rambunctious five-year-olds wait
no uh two
inquisitive ten-year-olds who are
curious about life
death and extended family do you have a
brother mom
i do he's
far away from here and that makes me
sad sometimes yes the tragedy of pietro
maximoff
killed by ultron while fighting
alongside the avengers the moment was a
major trauma in wanda's life
that has been brought up multiple times
in this series so far but the mcu pieter
never made it out of his first movie
there was another a different happier
piece oh
existed in the x-men films evan peters
quicksilver was arguably the best thing
in each of the movies he was in
and when his name showed up early on as
part of the one division cast
fans got to work trying to figure out
how he'd play into the story
so yeah even though it's not exactly a
huge surprise that he's now here
the way the show handles the reveal is
pretty brilliant
[Applause]
long lost bro get to squeeze his
stinking sister to death or what
[Music]
she recast pietro another beloved marvel
character that didn't make it past their
first appearance
sparky despite that big moment and all
the twists and reveals this episode
gives us
the best part hands down has got to be
elizabeth olsen and her performance
it's too sad you can fix anything mom
fix it dead you said family is forever
he is family bring him back mom
bring her back she really digs into the
complexities of wanda's character
struggling
with the demons of her past while trying
not to let this ideal life she's been
living
fall apart she may not have started all
this as we've come to learn
but she doesn't want it to end and she
continues to be the one that has to make
the difficult decisions
for her family what do you want i have
what i want
and no one will ever take it from me
again we even get the return of
versacovian accent which
is a nice touch gotta say folks i think
this is my favorite episode so far i
mean
it could be because i really love family
ties and growing pains
but the way this one peels back more
layers of mystery while having a lot of
fun dangling potential plot twists and
character reveals right in front of our
faces
just works with evan peters pietro
finally on board the door is wide open
for a big x-men twist not to mention who
is monica's aerospace engineer friend
and let's not forget
about this ongoing theory i had to ask
showrunner jack shaffer about
there's nathan philly in wonder man
um i i can't discuss such things any of
those could be a mark hamill in the
mandalorian level moment let the
speculation commence
in the comments below a like would be
great a subscribe would be awesome
either way
thanks for watching let's do this all
again next week
you